hello
i'm haris posides from ibm research and
together with my colleague tom parnell
we present to you snap ml accelerated
accurate efficient machinery we're both
excited to present
at pi data today and would like to thank
the organizers for the invitation
and you for for your attention so let's
get started
um slide so
snap ml or uh which is sort of snap
machine learning
is a library for optimized machine
learning
and it has been designed with two main
objectives in mind
first to accelerate and
scale some of the most popular classical
machine learning algorithms
accelerate the training and the
inference of those
through awareness at the system level
and second to develop novel machine
learning algorithms
that provide best-in-class accuracy
in particular for applications
so this is an overview of the snap ml
library today
starting from the left top
the snubbum library was started
with generalized linear models
in particular linear and logistic
regression and support vector machines
we implemented accelerated cpu and gpu
solvers for those
then moving on to
decision trees and random forests three
based models
also cpu and gpu solvers and more
recently
we have implemented a boosting machine
in the in this year early this year
we have released an improved version of
this boosting machine
and more recently we introduced
accelerated inference engines for
the three based models such as random
forest
decision trees and boosting machines
snap ml
is is written in c plus plus and cuda
the core library
we have implemented python wrappers that
offer the apis
we offer in all six
models the familiar scikit-learn python
api
and it has been offered to the public
as a free installation as part of the
ibm watson machine learning community
edition
as short overview of the solvers that we
offer today
can be seen in this table on the on the
bottom right
so for all of the six models we offer
cpu
accelerated cpu solvers multi-threaded
multi-threaded ones
gpu solvers for all as well as multi-gpu
solvers for
the generalized linear models and the
random force
we also offer distributed solvers for
the generalized linear models
and we are currently working on offering
multi-gpu boosting machine solvers
and multi-gpu and multi-node distributed
solvers for random forest and boosting
which we hope to offer in the first half
of next year
so with that i would like to give it
over to my colleague thomas parnell who
will take you through the rest of the
presentation
okay thank you harris um okay so i'm
going to start by talking a bit about
how snap ml is distributed and how it's
available today
so as harrison harris already the core
library is written
in c plus and cuda and then we
package that up into various different
packages that the user can install
so firstly in the top here we have the
watson machine learning community
edition distribution
so this is a set of anaconda my contour
packed with
gpu as well as mpi support
um there are two packages one is called
pi for sk
which is a snap ml with a scikit-learn
interface for single node use
and then there's snapml spark which is
um
apache spark api for use in
distributed environments so both of
these packages can be installed simply
by saying condo install python sk
after subscribing to the wml channel
and then what we're working on now is a
new distribution method
which is somewhat simpler um we're
building build apu only
wheels which we plan to upload in the
public pip index
this will be simply the psychic learn
api
for snap ml and it will be installable
via pip
install snap ml uh
okay harrison net slide please
okay so would like to talk about the
key research innovations behind
snap ml fml
so let me start with the gpu
acceleration that was our focus really
in the beginning
was on how can we accelerate
generalized linear models on gpus
so we started developing new uh
extremely parallel asynchronous
coordinate descent algorithms
which map very effectively onto gpu
hardware
as well as new algorithms which deal
with the case
when the the data set is too big to fit
in gpu memory
so these were some of the um earliest
research ideas that were going into
snapper ml
in um already 2017 and 2018.
after that we started shifting our focus
towards distributed training so
what you can do when you have a really
huge
data set uh
when you have maybe a cluster of high
performance cpus or
gpus based
and we developed a new algorithm called
adn adaptive distributed newton
for solving generalized linear models in
that kind of setup so when you have like
a
terascale data set and some of our
initial
demos with snapper ml were focused on
this huge data scenario
um after that we started thinking a bit
about
um what if you don't have gpus what if
you're in the
cloud and you don't want to spend a lot
of money on a gpu-based
instance um how can we exploit
modern multi-core and even multi-socket
cpus
in an effective way so that was some of
the research we were doing in 2018 2019
i'm going to show you some results with
that shortly
um again the idea is how can we train um
generalized linear models as well as
other models
very fast on modern cpu hardware
and finally that brings me to our um
current work and very recent research
which is around
ensemble methods so we started there
looking for how can we accelerate
training of
models like decision trees and random
forests
so we design new
hybrid training algorithms hybrid
between
our breadth first and depth first search
for training those
kinds of models and then we also started
asking how can we
improve the accuracy of models like
boosting machines so that was our most
recent work
into snap boost which is a new boosting
algorithm
um where we choose the base learner at
each boosting iteration
stochastically so by sampling from a
random
distribution and we show that um
using that approach you can get better
accuracy than xgb boost and light gbm
but without sacrificing performance
okay um next shot please
okay so this is a little bit about the
um api
so we can show you how
snap ml is used so in this example
we compare uh training and evaluating a
random forest
um on the left hand side with snap with
psychic learn
and on the right hand side with snap ml
um
so you see aside from the import uh
things look very similar
um we have mostly the same parameters as
psychic learn
our random states max depth and
estimators and jobs max features
we have some additional ones and we'll
want um
use histograms this is a optimization
that splits each node using histogram
statistics instead of searching through
all of the possible values which can
bring a lot of acceleration
as well as use gpu and gpu ids which
um tell snapemo whether it should use
the gpu or not
and then how many gpus to use and which
ids it should use
finally when we look at the actual
training and inference you see that it
adheres to the
scikit-learn api we have fit predict
functions we have predict
proper score and all um
everything that's it defined by the
scikit-learn api
um next shot please so similarly uh we
have the boosting machine
here um
as you may know xgboost has its
own api but it also exposes a
scikit-learn adherent api called xgb
classifier and xtp regressor here we
show an example with the classifier
so you set the an estimator's max depth
learning array
tree method equals gpu to tell it to use
the gpu
as well as the number of cpu threads and
jumps
and on the right hand side you see the
snap boost api again it's very similar
instead of setting the max depth we can
set a min max depth and max max depth
this is um part of the stochastic
element of snap boost it can choose the
max step for each iteration
randomly between the min and the max
and we also support gpu acceleration via
the
use gpu flag here and again the fit and
predict
follows the um widely popular cycle
learn api
so it can plug into any uh pipelines or
applications which may be expecting
estimators
with those methods
okay so here's um like a full
work example of um
train training a logistic regression
from sniper ml and evaluating it
what we want to show really with this
slide is that um
snapperml can plug into
applications which are using the
scikit-learn ecosystem
so that means you can
reuse the data loading the
pre-processing the model selection
and metrics functionality from psychic
learn you don't need to implement
everything from scratch or use
new stuff from snapeml you can simply uh
replace the training part
uh replace the estimator from
scikit-learn with snap ml
and all of the rest remains the same
[Music]
okay so now we're going to talk a bit
about the
performance of sniper ml in terms of
training so firstly
we have a benchmark comparing
snappamerlag and psychic learn
for logistic regression so very
popular generalized linear model
we have five different data sets here um
they involve various different use cases
we have
computational advertising financial
services
retail as well as scientific computation
the higgs dataset and we
um deploy snapml on a fairly powerful
server here
but we're only using um four threads
for each model both for scikit-learn as
well as snap ml
um and what you see here
in time so um there are
two things we want to to draw your
attention to here
so first so firstly all five of these
data sets the
training time is significantly less so
i'm more than a factor of 10
up to a factor of 120 121 sorry
and the next thing is to look at the auc
so the
the study on the test set now uh
generalized logistic regression is a
convex
optimization problem so there is a
single
solution and indeed most of the time
psychic learn and snap them out exactly
in the auc
a couple of cases where you see sniper
ml is better
and that's actually because the
scikit-learn
solver failed to converge so as of the
most recent
um version of psychic learn lbfgs
is their default solver and it's not
converging on these datasets so we could
let it run for longer
and it might get to the ultimate to the
correct solution
but of course then it's gonna um take
even longer than you see
here so um the technology behind these
speedups
is um related to the multi-threaded cpu
based algorithms i mentioned earlier so
none of these speed ups are coming from
gpu
i want to make that crystal clear um
this is
purely um coming from
optimized cpu algorithm and this was um
showcased in the
europe's conference last year where it
got a spotlight presentation
okay next slide please
so again similar benchmark again is cpu
only
um but this time entry algorithm from
snap ml
comparing psychic learn as well as
um it's another ml
so here again we see here we see six
data sets
again in the data sets correspond to
domains like retail
advertising and financial services
again we see some speed ups varying from
uh
four four x one rosmann up to
um 30x on the credit card
and that here we have a mixture of
regression
and classification
problems because decision trees can be
used for both
so in all cases we see that the mean
squared error is either lower
or the auc is higher for the
classification problems
so we don't sacrifice any accuracy
in order to get this accelerated
um next slide please
okay so similar vein this is the random
forest
algorithm from um psychic learn so
uh from snapping on a cyclone so
around the forest is an ensemble of
decision trees the random forest is a
much more complex model
than a single decision tree so the
absolute training times
increase a lot compared to the previous
chart
but we see that the um acceleration
factors remain similar
so we have a minimum speed up of 5x
up to a maximum speed up of 31x
and again for the classification
problems we see that the auc
is higher and for the regression
problems the msc
is very slightly here's almost exactly
the same
and here is slightly better using snap
ml
okay next chart please
okay so um in this chart we we
compare against a different framework um
so we
also switch gears a bit uh in the
previous three benchmarks we were
looking at the cpu
performance and now we're looking at the
gpu performance
and we're comparing here to the qml
framework from nvidia which is a
software for accelerated classical
machine learning
on gpus so on the left hand side we
compare for
uh ridge regression uh which is like a
l2 regularized linear regression
and on the right for logistic first for
classification problems
and the y-axis here shows the speed up
we achieved
over um qml so we see
in some cases um qml was ever so
slightly better
and in other cases snappermill was 164
times better
68 times better on logistic and this
these speed ups are coming from the fact
that we solve the problem
using fundamentally different algorithms
than cool ml
and this is this is um related to the
core research
technology which is underpinning the
snuff and wealth framework
okay next chart please
okay so now i'd like to talk a bit about
the
accuracy games that one can achieve
using
uh snappermill and in particular using a
snapboost
or boosting machine so
um this is one of the first benchmarks
we did with
snapboost in the beginning um using the
openml platform so openml is like a
platform for collaborative data science
it has it hosts
thousands of data sets um which you can
easily download download using
which makes it uh well suited for doing
these kind of benchmarks where you
it's very it's very important to compare
different boosting machines using a
large number of data sets
because uh with a single data set it's
hard to
say um which one is really better you
need a large sample
enable to be able to make um conclusive
um insights about that so here we took
48 data sets from openml and we
performed hyper parameter tuning as well
as
um cross validation to do
generalization estimation so we use the
process known as nested
cross validation in order to estimate
the test error
correctly as well as to tune the hyper
parameters of
all three models and so on the left-hand
side we compare
the snap boost against fly gbm and in
the
the red bars on are the data sets when
light gpm
was better in terms of the test loss
and the blue data sets in the bottom
are the cases where snap boost achieved
a
better test loss lower test loss
so we see that snap boosts 1 and 31 out
of 48
and in some cases the improvement was
very significant
similarly on the right hand panel we
compare with xg boost and there we see a
similar conclusion
that snap boost achieved better
test loss in 32 of the 48 data sets
under test next chart please
okay so here
we compare snap boost again against xp
boost and live gpm
but now on a different set of data sets
so
openml is great for benchmarking because
as i said before
it has a lot of data sets but the
datasets are often quite small
um and also they're they're very often
synthetic or kind of toy data sets that
people have been using
um in the machine learning community for
quite some time
what we wanted to do with this benchmark
was to take some more um
realistic and more interesting use cases
so we took
three data sets from the kaggle platform
so um kaggle is a
platform where people compete to see who
can find the
most accurate machine learning solution
for various different interesting tasks
so in this case
um the three use cases we looked at
was credit card fraud detection and then
a retail
data set where the goal is to predict
the sales of
different stores to the sales volume and
another is
this makari price suggestion where you
want to
predict the optimal price for different
products based on characteristics and
customer preferences and so on
so um as you may be aware in kaggle
often the winning solution is um
using xgb boost or light gpm in some
capacity
so actually kaggle is really where these
frameworks
made the name for themselves
and what we see here is that on all
three of these use cases
um when we compare the
test metric whether it's log loss or
root mean squared error for the
progression problems
we see that snapboost um is beating xgb
boost in like gpm
and i'd like to emphasize that this is
after
hyperparameter tuning so um
this is the tuned uh test loss
for these three different frameworks
so again uh this is our most recent
research and we just
um had our paper on snapboost accepted
to the eurips conference which will take
place
in december so please check out that
paper for more details
next job please okay so finally this is
um
a real industrial application of
snapboost this was a
ibm customer in the financial services
domain who came to
us saying that they have a gradient
boosting workload
they were actually using a different
framework they were using the
gbm from h2o that's about all we know
they wouldn't tell us the data set or
the learning task
and they ran all of the experiments
themselves and this is what they
reported back to us
basically they compared the h2o boosting
machine
excuse me
they compare the h2o boosting machine
after extensive
hyper parameter tuning with the
snapboost
algorithm again after extensive
hyperparameter tuning
are both here running on the gpu
and they found that snapboost could give
them 12
improved accuracy and the end to end run
time was very similar so the total time
it took them to do the tuning um
was around 20 minutes in both cases
okay next slide please
okay so now we're going to talk about
the
the inference acceleration aspect of
snapmall which is again
um some of our very recent work
so the goal with inference acceleration
is
of course primarily to accelerate
inference
but we also want to do it in a portable
way
so what we mean by that is um if a
customer or user has a model which
they've
pre-trained in xd boost or light gbm or
maybe
another boosting framework
we want to be able to accelerate the
inference
of that model within snapper ml
seamlessly so we want to be able to
um score accelerated scoring for
snap boost for models trained with snap
boots
but also we want to be able to import
models trains with other frameworks so
we can offer
the same acceleration um for
xg boost models and for light bm models
so what you see here
is a benchmark on the credit card fraud
data set
and we have a model which was
pre-trained uh in
xg boost and on the x-axis
is the the depth of the tree and on the
y-axis is the inference latency
so this is single record inference so uh
we're
scoring a single record at a time and
sending it back to the user
and what we see we see in red women's
have actually boost with one
two and four threads um you as you'll
see exercise is not particularly
well it is not able to benefit from
multi-threading particularly well
for single record inference
whereas um if we if we import
that pre-trained xg boos model into snap
ml
uh even with one thread we have a
significant speed up
over the xg boost scoring engine
and then as we add two or four threads
that speed up continues to grow
so in the um maximum case
at depth 16 we have a speed up of around
4x
and you'll notice here that the speed up
is growing with the complexity
of the model
and on the next chart we have the same
benchmark but a different data set so
this is epsilon which is a
more complex data set in that it has
many more features than
the credit card fraud and this is also
running on a different platform so this
is running on ibm z
on the mainframe z14 so
ibm customers run a lot of transactional
workloads on
um such systems where they want to do
you know like real time prediction
using machine learning and here we see
an even bigger speed up so using a
threads we have a 32x speedup
over um the extra boost scoring engine
and again this is the same model so the
accuracy is the same in all cases the
model was trained in a different
platform using xgboost and then
imported into the snappermill engine and
evaluated
on the ge mainframe system
okay um so yeah this is
what we're approaching the end now just
some of our closing remarks so
there's a there's a whole lot of
research which has gone into
um this package um
many publications in europe and icml
um a lot of workshop and talks
so please if you're interested in the
algorithms and their implementations go
and check out some of the papers
um and next shot please so
finally would just like to talk about
how you can try it so how to get
snappermill how to install it
so if you remember in the beginning we
said that stanford ml is currently
available
through watson machine learning
community edition
so at this url you can find the
instructions for how to install
what's a machine learning ce it's very
simple you simply
um subscribe to our conda channel and
then you can install
say the pi for sdk package using corner
installed python sk
we have packages for power as well as
xtc6 so this is not
ipm specific you can run on any x86
machine
but right now we're specific to linux so
we don't provide packages for
mac os and so on um
as i mentioned before we're working on
the uh
pipey packaging so we hope that
later this month or next month it should
be possible to install
snapmail via pip install sniper ml
uh you can find the latest documentation
at this url
as well as on tutorials and examples at
this one
and we have some video tutorials here
and you could find out more um with all
of these different links at our project
homepage
zurich.ibm.com snapperml
okay i think that brings us to the end
of the presentation thank you very much
for your attention and
uh please reach out if you have any um
questions or interest in snap of mill
thank you though and thank you everybody
i hope you enjoyed we hope you enjoyed
this presentation
and thank you for your attention